russia's invasion of crimea is plainly
unacceptable and the upcoming
self-determination referendum is
outright illegal
that was the message as europe spoke as
one voice
the eu has outlined an 11 billion euro
financial aid package for ukraine and
threatened moscow's sanctions
with mep's pressing for a rapid response
to the crisis and the only way to stop
it
that is to be bold to be courageous with
the european union and to do what is
necessary
up to 356 billion euros that's how much
money laundering is alleged across
europe in 2012.
the parliament has just given the eu a
new weapon to tackle this
eu-wide public registers to identify the
beneficiaries of suspected funds
for the criminals who want to use
europe's stable
stable political environment stable
banking system
as a haven for their illicitly gained
monies this is a terrible day
the seed market in europe breaks in
seven billion euros
the european commission intended to
regulate production on the market
on the parliament side meps didn't want
this some
concerned that it would give too much
power to the commission and give
international stakeholders a chance to
monopolize the market
therefore mep shunned the proposed text
and sent it back to the commission
with their representative being heckled
in the chamber traditional varieties